♪ ♪
>> Sean: HERE WITH MORE
REACTION TO ALL OF TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS, AUTHOR OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLE
BEST SELLER, THE TRUTH ABOUT OUR
NATION'S GREAT COMEBACK, FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NEWT GINGRICH.
THE LIST IS PRETTY AMAZING.
IT REALLY IS AWESOME.
HERE'S A QUESTION, ARE WE BETTER
OFF AS A COUNTRY THEN WE WERE
JUST TWO SHORT YEARS AGO WITH
4 MILLION NEW JOBS, 8 MILLION
FEWER AMERICANS IN POVERTY ON
FOOD STAMPS.
LET'S SEE, A PATH TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, THREE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS ON A BORDER
WALL.
NORTH KOREA, IRAN.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK ON SECURITY, ECONOMIC
ISSUES, RECORDS IN 14 STATES,
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, I THINK WE'RE
BETTER OFF, BUT WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> I THINK WE ARE BETTER OFF BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
ELECTION IS ABOUT.
THIS ELECTION IS A
LIFE-AND-DEATH STRUGGLE WITH A
LEFT-WING MOVEMENT THAT WANTS TO
LEAD DEMOCRATIC ALLIES AMERICA.
YOU ARE HAPPY THAT THERE ARE
MORE PEOPLE AT WORK.
THAT TOOK PEOPLE OFF OF FOOD
STAMPS.
IT MEANT THERE WERE NO LONGER
DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT SO IF
YOU ARE A LEFT-WING DEMOCRAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY BAD, NOT GOOD.
I KNOW IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE BUT
I HAVE A PREDICTION FOR YOU.
SOMETIMES POLITICIANS AND THEIR
CONSULTANTS AND EVERYBODY DOES
ALL THIS PLANNING AND THEN
HISTORY JUST PICK THINGS UP AND
CHANGES EVERYTHING.
I THINK TWO WORDS ARE GOING TO
DEFINE THE NIGHT OF THE 2018
ELECTION IN THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS.
ONE IS KAVANAUGH AND THE OTHER
IS CARAVAN.
AND THE COMBINATION OF ANGER
OVER HOW THE LEFT SMEARED,
ENGAGED IN CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, LIVE, USED
BULLYING TACTICS WITH JUDGE
KAVANAUGH IS GOING TO BE ONE
PART OF THIS AND THE DEGREE TO
WHICH THE LEFT IS EAGER TO HAVE
3,000 PEOPLE IN A CARAVAN ACROSS
THE AMERICAN BORDER, BREAK
AMERICAN LAW, RECOGNIZING THAT
IF THAT HAPPENS, THE NEXT
CARAVAN WILL BE EVEN BIGGER IN
THE CARAVAN AFTER THAT WILL BE
EVEN BIGGER AND I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
REJECT BOTH THE WAY THEY TREATED
KAVANAUGH IN THE WAY THEY ARE
DEALING WITH BORDER AND I THINK
THOSE WILL END UP BEING THE
REASONS THE REPUBLICANS KEEP THE
HOUSE AND DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF SENATORS THEY HAV
HAVE.
>> Sean: MR. SPEAKER,
ELECTIONS ARE USUALLY ABOUT
PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
I'M LOOKING AT THE ECONOMY,
EVERY MEASURE WE ARE DOING
BETTER.
THIS IS WHAT I HEAR FROM THE
DEMOCRATS, IMPEACHMENT, BUT
DON'T SAY IT.
OPEN BORDERS, BUT DON'T SAY IT.
WANT THEIR CRIMES BACK, THEY
WANT OBAMACARE AND THEY WANT
ENDLESS INVESTIGATIONS INTO
TERM.
I DON'T HEAR ONE THING THAT THEY
ARE RUNNING ON THAT WOULD
BENEFIT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
OBAMACARE?
A DISASTER.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
PROPOSALS FOR GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTH CARE, WHICH WOULD BE
IMPOSSIBLE TO PAY FOR, WOULD
BANKRUPT THE SYSTEM, CRUSH THE
ENTIRE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND DESTROY MEDICARE, YOU
LOOK AT ALL THOSE THINGS, YOU
HAVE TO WONDER WHAT ARE THESE
PEOPLE THINKING?
AND YET DEMOCRAT AFTER DEMOCRAT
HAS SIGNED UP FOR A PROGRAM
WHICH I THINK ABSOLUTELY WOULD
COLLAPSE MEDICARE AND ABSOLUTELY
WOULD ELIMINATE ALL OF THE
EMPLOYER-BASED INSURANCE
SYSTEMS, WHICH IS WHAT
BERNIE SANDERS SAYS HE WANTS TO
DO.
HE WANTS TO FORCE YOU AND ME AND
EVERYONE ELSE INTO A SINGLE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEM THAT HE GETS
TO DEFINE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I'M VERY HOPEFUL.
I THINK THERE'S A REALLY GOOD
SHOT -- RICK SCOTT, A GREAT
GOVERNOR.
I REALLY FEEL CONFIDENT IN THE
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT JOSH
HAWLEY WILL WIN, WHO WE JUST HAD
ON FOR MISSOURI AS CLAIRE
McCASKILL HAS BEEN EXPOSED AND
THE SAME WITH BLACKBURN AFTER
BRETT IS AND HAS BEEN EXPOSED
AND I'M HOPING DEAN HELLER, THE
LATEST POLLS HAVE HIM UP.
HE'S ALWAYS IN A TOUGH RACE IN
NEVADA AND I THINK HE'S IN
TROUBLE IN MONTANA.
HEIDI HEITKAMP IS NOW IN DOUBLE
DIGITS, AS SHOULD BE IN
NORTH DAKOTA, JOE DONNELLY IN
INDIANA.
I THINK WE CAN WIN EVERYONE OF
THOSE RACES.
THE ONLY THING THAT WORRIES ME
TONIGHT, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
HOUSE.
DON'T HAVE A BIG MARGIN THERE.
>> LET ME ADD TO YOUR HAPPINESS.
I THINK WE HAVE A REAL SHOT IN
MINNESOTA.
NEW JERSEY.
THE SENATE COULD BECOME -- YOU
REMEMBER IN 1980 WHEN I WAS
WORKING WITH THE REAGAN TEAM, WE
ENDED UP PICKING UP 12 SENATE
SEATS, CONTROL OF THE SENATE,
NOBODY EXPECTED.
WE PICKED UP 12 SENATE SEATS IN
ONE NIGHT.
SO THIS COULD BECOME A BIG
BLOWOUT.
THE HOUSE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
TROUBLE BUT I THINK WHAT KEVIN
McCARTHY IS DOING IN
INTRODUCING A BILL TO GAIN
CONTROL OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND I WOULD URGE KEVIN TO
CHALLENGE NANCY TELL MIKE
NANCY PELOSI TO A NATIONAL
DEBATE.
LET HER DEFEND THE TOTAL FAILURE
TO CONTROL THE AMERICAN BORDER,
TO PROTECT AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY,
TO DRAW A LINE IN THE SAND AND
SAY NO MORE, TO WELCOME CARAVANS
AND ALSO A DELIBERATE EFFORT TO
UNDERMINE THE AMERICAN SYSTEM
AND LET KEVIN EXPLAIN THE BILL
HE'S GOT THAT HE WANTS TO BRING
UP IN DECEMBER THAT CONTROLS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
I THINK IF THE CHOICE IS THAT
CLEAR, IF OVER HERE YOU'VE GOT
SANCTUARY CITIES, MS-13,
FENTANYL, OPIOID DEATHS, ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THE DEMOCRATS
SEEM TO ACCEPT, AND OVERHEAR YOU
HAVE A PARTY DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING YOU, PROTECTING YOUR
FAMILY, PROTECTING YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD, I THINK WE WILL DO
JUST FINE ELECTION NIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU VOTE FOR ANY
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE YOU ARE
VOTING FOR PELOSI.
VOTE FOR ANY DEMOCRATIC SENATOR,